hello everyone and welcome to the third
in a series of three on-air programs the
first was about getting started with GCP
and what you can build quickly the
second was about machine learning and
how you can inspire love and your
customers the third is about bringing
GCP close to you my name is Neil Mueller
I work on the geographic expansion team
of GCP hi I'm Dave stiver I'm a p.m. for
our geo expansion efforts I've been at
Google for the last 12 years really
building out the compute storage and
networking infrastructure that's a long
time - yeah it's part of what we really
use to bring GCP to you great let's get
started we've got a bunch of content
before I get started I want to tell you
that you can leave questions for us
anytime up until the the end of our of
our presentation we're gonna answer all
your questions at the very end we'll get
to them for sure I'll try to get to
every single one of them we're going to
talk for about 30 minutes and then we're
going to answer your questions for about
15 ok great let's get going so just a
little bit of context why are we doing
this why are we putting regions all over
the world they're really three main
requirements that we look out for
customers the number one reason is
performance they're looking for low
latency applications so we have to put
our infrastructure close to you and
close to your customers the second
reason is high availability they want
multiple locations to select from in
order for them to meet their business
continuity dates and build highly
available applications and then the last
one is really control we put these
locations in different parts of the
world because customers really want
control over where they build their
applications and where they store their
data it's really important that we bring
the product to you and you as customers
get to pick where you want your data to
live okay so if you look at this
infrastructure investment Google has
really been a cloud company for the last
decade but if you think about what cloud
is doing even at Google scale we made a
huge investment in our infrastructure
just in the last three years if you look
at just the last three years spend it's
been over 30 billion dollars which even
at Google scale is a pretty large
investment so this isn't something small
that we're doing it's something that's
fundamental to the company as Eric
Schmidt said in our last next in San
Francisco last summer we built a cloud
this big so that you don't
- to give you an idea about how big our
cloud looks physically
let's bring ourselves to the Netherlands
so Dave and I just launched our new
region in the Netherlands last month yes
a couple weeks ago not long ago although
I didn't get a chance to see this data
center I had to share a couple of the
pictures with you to give you an idea
this is our Netherlands data center
which has a variety of Google services
Google search YouTube a number of other
services and then a GCP region inside it
as well you can see in the distance some
windmills that are used to power this
this region with renewable energy
security is something we take very
seriously this is what the exterior
security looks like as you can see the
security guard shack is covered with
grass which I thought was particularly
beautiful on the inside there are
different cells of the data center which
separate different cells from each other
we operate the products within Google
very separately you can see we've got a
man trapped here with an iris scanner
and a physical guard shack just one note
on that I think to build on what Neal
said is it's important to understand
right we have data centers all over the
world but we use the same system of
physical and logical security in order
to make sure that your data stays safe
it looks a little bit different at the
data center level wherever you go in the
world but it's the same model that we
use everywhere nice ok I mentioned
something about the environment and how
we use renewable energy how we've
reached 100% renewable energy to power
our data centers globally another thing
that's kind of interesting and I'll let
you guys in on a little secret
is that when we first built this data
center a couple of years ago we
discovered from ecologist that we were
going to disrupt a bat habitat so our
local site reliability engineers and
local officials teamed up together to
build this thing that we call a bat cave
this bat cave houses a habitat of bats
that you can see in the upper left-hand
corner of this picture that are about
the size of your finger and with the
result of this bat cave their habitat
wasn't disrupted and we were able to
build this this data center if the data
center filling up is any indication of
how much the bats are gonna start
filling up we'll soon have to build
another bat cave yeah
this is a picture of a solar farm very
close to the Netherlands data center
that produces enough solar energy to
power the Netherlands data center you
can see the windmills in the distance to
a note on energy not only have we
reached a hundred percent renewable
energy by either consuming renewable
energy itself or by buying enough
offsets but we also use less energy in
our data centers than the industry
average the industry average PUA which
is a measure of effectiveness how much
energy we're consuming versus how much
energy we're wasting the industry
average is 1.7 Google's across Google's
global average across all of our data
centers is 1.1 - that's much much less -
is bad and one is really great one means
that every energy that you're taking in
you're using to power the data center -
means that for every piece of energy are
taking in you're wasting an equivalent
atom of energy at the same time so we're
1.1 - in the industry average is 1.7
this means that we can build data
centers like this that operate at very
high performance but consume appreciably
less energy than any other data centers
that we've been able to find in the
world there's a really interesting
parallel there - to drop between the
data center infrastructure in the cloud
world things that are important to
Google are being open with our
technology and so when we were doing all
that work back in 2008-2009 in order to
improve our data center efficiency we
got done with all that work and then we
published all of that externally we
shared it with the world
we essentially wrote the script or the
playbook for how other people could get
that kind of data center efficiency so
it's one of the proudest I was building
data center infrastructure at that time
so it's really one of the proudest
moments I had then we took all of that
IP and made it publicly available to
everybody
the corollary really in the cloud world
is something like kubernetes where we
take a really fundamental core
technology and then open source it yeah
so open source is super critical to us
we're committed to that as a company
both at the data center infrastructure
level and at the cloud level Wow great
so if we think a little bit about how we
layer cloud over the top of all that
data center infrastructure we can talk a
couple dimensions and the first
dimension is probably cloud location
so we have multiple versions of this
that you can think of to choose from as
a customer and we'll build from the
inside out so we'll start with zones you
can think of zones as independent
failure domains within a region so
they're independent across multiple
dimensions of the physical
infrastructure so they have isolation
across power cooling networking and
probably most importantly the control
plane is isolated as well in these zones
so you can choose these individually and
then if you put a couple of zones
together - usually we have three zones
per region you you combine a couple of
them together and you get a region so
regions are geographically independent
locations so an example of one of our
oldest regions is in Iowa where we have
one in Belgium or one that we launched
last year Tokyo those are all cloud
regions that customers can choose then
beyond that if you combine multiple
regions together you get what's called a
multi region and that's a product
offering we have where you can choose
that and essentially we combine multiple
regions that are geographically separate
from one another together into a product
offering that gives you that level of
isolation and higher availability and
then the last one is global global is a
service that's essentially spread
everywhere in the world where Google
data center infrastructure lives so
that's something where you don't even
have to think about the location it's
just automatically spread everywhere in
the world and I think it's worth maybe
walking through a couple examples of not
just the locations but now how do the
services deploy on top of those that
makes sense yeah let's do it okay so a
couple of the product or service
deployment models I mentioned we have
regional offerings so something like
compute engine is a regional or zonal
product you can choose a zone in any
region around the world compute engine
is sort of fundamental right - the
infrastructure of GCP so you can pick in
Oregon or Northern Virginia all of our
locations another example is our object
storage product cloud storage has a it
has both a regional and a multi regional
offerings so you can choose today a
bucket in the Americas or in Europe or
in Asia and when you upload your data we
will automatically replicate that data
to those different regions for that
multi-regional offering to give you the
the higher availability and then the
last offering is global
we have a product like pub/sub our
messaging service which is inherently
everywhere in the world so that data and
those messages get spread everywhere
where we have infrastructure and have
pub/sub running depending on where your
customers are good three different
offerings so let's talk about a tool
that customers can use if they've got
questions yeah don't take it from me so
well
we'll leave the slides and we'll go to
the actual Internet now we're gonna
navigate to a website that's visible to
all you guys it's cloud google.com slash
about slash locations the top of the
website looks like this but if you
scroll down past the map you're gonna
see what Dave and I call the matrix so
it's walking through the matrix yeah so
we haven't broken up by each market
today it's the Americas it's Europe and
Asia Pacific as we continue to add
regions will add more continents
probably but let's look at two services
just so you can quickly get an example
each column is a region and then each
row is a service so compute engine as I
mentioned is kind of a fundamental core
product in GCP today it's already
available in every single region in GCP
and that's sort of the goal that's where
we want to get where as much of GCP is
available in every single region that we
launched that we have available today if
you drop down and look at instorage see
something like cloud BigTable soup Euler
super popular product newer than compute
engine it's actually trailing a little
bit behind like we we launched regions
faster than we could keep services
growing but as you paced through if you
look through the different markets you
see that over the course of this year
BigTable will start to show up in more
and more locations it's super important
that you know that we're bringing all of
GCP to you in each one of these
locations so we're working through our
product list prioritizing and
regionalizing
as much of GCP as we can as quickly as
possible to make sure that every region
you pick is a consistent user experience
we do these kind of presentations in
front of customers a lot and when we do
them we invent words soup cooler is not
like a favorite invented where'd you put
that one in the book that's a good one
we'll scroll down here just so the folks
can see as you can see all of our
products are here listed and you can
tell where they are just by looking at
the matrix okay
to the slides you all let you take this
one nice okay so we've talked about the
15 regions where we serve GCP customers
mmm you can think of these into three
big buckets Americas Europe and Asia
Pacific on the x-axis here we have all
of these 15 regions starting with Iowa
and ending all the way over here with
Sydney on the y-axis we have how much
this costs for course now you could do
this for storage or for big data or for
machine learning or networking it would
follow a very similar trend line what
you're seeing here is that the cost of
providing TCP services to you
in the Americas is a little bit less
than in Europe and a little bit less in
Asia Pacific this is true across all of
the cloud providers and also within
within Google why is that Dave so the
cop part of it is just the cost of doing
business varies like the cost of energy
is different in each one of these
locations or the cost of land part of it
is the age of the facility so their
efficiencies that you get the longer
that facility is up and running and the
last one is just economies of scale so
you can see here if you look at the
oldest regions are the largest regions
and as we grow we get and more and more
customers we get economies of scale and
that allows us to drop prices so what
you can see here is as a DCP customer
you can pick wherever you want to run
workloads if you want the workload to be
very close to you you're gonna benefit
from the speed of light benefits of it
being very nearby you if you're willing
to let it be a little bit further away
you can go for you're now empowered with
the information and to know where to buy
that for the less at least least amount
of money but I'd be remiss if I didn't
talk a bit about pricing as compared to
other cloud providers as long as we're
talking about us so we have a number of
pricing philosophies within GCP that are
very advantageous to customers we call
it customer friendly pricing one of them
is called sustained use discounts which
I've abbreviated in the slide Sud now
what sustained use discount says is if
you're going to use a piece of compute
for 25% or more of the month you are
granted a discount this is just
automatic you don't have to apply for it
or send any emails making phone calls
you just get it on your bill
if you use it for the entirety of the
month you can get up to a 30% discount
so think if you use it for 30 days you
get a 30% discount it's a nice nice easy
mnemonic so you can see our list prices
are listed here in the height of the
blue bar if you subtract from that 30%
you will see the sub price sustained use
discount now just as a comparison I've
posted what Amazon's price was as of a
couple of days ago when I made this
slide and you can see what it is right
here so you can see that the general
price increases from Americas to Europe
and Asia is also with Amazon and in
general we are much much less when you
account for sustained use discount
we are appreciably less than other
public cloud providers including Amazon
okay so just to give a little bit of
context to how we've grown if you look
back I think 18 months we had four
regions around the world and today we
have 15 so that's like 300% growth in in
the last 18 months which even at Google
scale is significant you can see all of
our launch regions here in the map are
in blue and then we have four new
regions that we've already announced
that are coming so Finland Los Angeles
Osaka which is our second region in
Japan we just announced that one which
is important for D are in Japan and then
Hongkong are all coming in 2018 there
are additional regions coming as well
we'll talk a little bit about that later
on but we have many more in the pipeline
this is just what we've announced so far
nice the next website that we'd like to
show you in addition to these slides is
like a tool that you all can use it's
called GC Peng comm we make this a
little bit bigger so you guys can read
it so this is a website that shows you
which region might be best for you
now you might pick best based on cost
but you might pick best based on speed
and all the advancements that Google
does around our network we still can't
adjust the speed of light it is what it
is and so the physically closest region
to you is going to be the fastest
response time and this tool is a way for
you to figure that out so let's let's do
a race let's click here
and we'll figure out which is the
closest region to us I'm guessing it's
going to be Oregon the one after that
is gonna be Iowa where I was born and
then as we move eastward it'll be e to
another in Virginia and then Montreal
what's the farthest region from us it's
Mumbai 304 milliseconds
still not bad even though it's on the
other side of the world yeah interesting
to note that this test goes over the
public circuits if you were using the
Google's private network which will tell
you about in a second it would be less
than that up to half the latency so 150
milliseconds to Mumbai
okay back slots
do you think yep just to give you a
little bit of context visually for how
we this what this launch velocity looks
like one of the things that we decided
maybe two years ago was we just weren't
keeping face keeping pace with the speed
of our customers and what they needed
for us so we spent almost a year really
building out a set of automation tools
to allow us to quickly turn up a new
region so everything in our stack from
the lowest level of infrastructure right
every dim every server every rack all
the way up to the top of the stack our
managed services offering have all been
automated so that we can stand up a set
of new zones and a region in a
relatively short amount of time so you
can see sort of what our launch velocity
look like there in in 2015 and 2016 what
we've been up to in 2017 and then what
we have in store in 2018 so your
automation is why you were able to
tumble them out so quick in 2017
yeah without that we never would have
been able to do this we'd be talking
about seven or eight or ten regions not
15 and from what I'm hearing from you
it's probably gonna just continue
correct okay yep yeah it's worth for
each one of those new region launch as I
mentioned you know we're trying to put
every service in all locations but right
now this is sort of a standard offering
that we have and it cuts across all the
dimensions of GCP whether it's compute
storage big data networking or our AM
services it's something that we put into
every location I did highlight a few
services because we just finished the
work on those cloud spanner and cloud
BigTable will now be a part of every new
region launch going forward so you won't
have to wait for that cloud bigquery has
extensive plans to roll out to more
locations in 2018 and we'll get them
caught up shortly so that critical sort
of key feature a GCP cloud bigquery will
be available everywhere for you you're
gonna put spanner BigTable and bigquery
in every single new region that's what
we said 18 months ago how would we
possibly do that that automation is the
way that so we could expect Hongkong
Osaka Finland LA all of them will have
those three that you bolded they're
absolutely fantastic
you want me to take this you can start
I'll finish okay so we talked a lot
about regions we talked a lot about
services but one of the things we don't
sometimes I think talk about enough is
the investment that we've made in our
network infrastructure we've been
building out this global network for
over the last 15 years really and it's
kind of the secret sauce of Google we
have an expression a decade ago almost
now that said it's all about the network
and it really is it's the tie that binds
so you take this network infrastructure
investment combine it with all the
regions combine it with the edge caches
and the points of presences we have and
it really becomes this sort of global
scale computer that you can program on
top on top of it's one of all of our
engineers here at Google program on top
of its what they become accustomed to be
careful once you get used to how fast it
is you talked about you know how much
better the latency is be careful once
you get used to how fast it is it's hard
to go back to the to the public Internet
but this is really a significant part of
that infrastructure investment the only
thing I would add is if you've ever used
Google comm and the brilliance of search
you have experienced this network
it's the distributed computing problem
that Google solved long before I joined
Google was solved with a network like
this and it'll it'll empower your
business to solve incredibly delightful
and joyous user experiences like we've
done with Google comm ok what's the
expression the expression is politics is
local yeah so all politics is local all
energy is local I like to say that all
cloud is really local too so these
region launches are not just about
putting data centers in places they're
really about us bringing GCP and meeting
customers where they're at so this is
we've been out launching these regions
for the last 18 months going to
different locations and it's more than
just a data center it's it's a lot more
than that in terms of opening up a new
market
yeah it's about helping local customers
with local sales people and local tech
support people and engaging local
engineers because Google has engineers
all over the world to give you a flavor
for this we've got to Anna Mae
gifts in one photo so let's just start
with the one on the left okay so the one
on the left is about our German region
launch which happened right around
Oktoberfest of last year it was
incredible on the left in that picture
you see or holtsville who's Google's
first vice president he's been at Google
a long time 16 18 years long time he's
heavily engaged with the geographic
expansion of GCP on his left is Michael
cor Bakr who is in charge of the
customer team in Germany and Austria and
Switzerland and there they're pressing a
buzzer in front of an audience of 300
customers as they open the first region
in Germany it was really exciting in the
middle we've got someone that I
recognize Dave Stivers is there pressing
the button with our head of European
customer team pH so he and pH are
opening up the first region in the
Netherlands that was just a couple weeks
ago yeah on the right hand side is
really what we want to do for every
region launch you see on the right side
of the picture you see two members of
our product team Maya and miles Ward 2
miles is right you see Chris Clicquot
who's in charge of North American
customer team in the middle you have the
mayor of Montreal because building
regions has a lot to do with the entire
region not just about the data center
that's there to the mayor's right we've
got two of our bigger customers and then
to their right is our country head of
Canada for Google cloud so we take
opening up these new regions very
seriously it's more than just a rack of
compute
it's about rooms and rooms and rooms of
people that are there to help you with
your problems to help sell you cloud and
to help you solve solve your problems I
don't want to set the wrong expectation
but just you know in 2017 we launched
almost one region a month ten new
regions in 2017 we didn't quite get to
one a month but we almost got there so
far in 2018 we're almost already doing
two months so the Netherlands at a
Montreal launched you know within a day
of one another so we're setting a high
bar already in the first month of 2018 I
don't know if we can keep up but we'll
try it's fun to work on yeah let's talk
about where we're gonna build next yeah
I mentioned this at the beginning of the
discussion we're not done yet we're
thinking about lots of locations if you
look at the map of the world which I
stare at all the time I spend 50% of my
time really talking to customers in
different part of the world trying to
figuring out what they need and then the
other 50% figuring out how do we do the
launch in this particular location so we
would love to hear from you here's some
spots that were already in and then some
spots that we're thinking about landing
you can expect to see additional
locations and markets we've already gone
to like we launched Osaka Osaka in Japan
so Alaska Hawaii that's just because we
highlighted America right correct
okay got it yep and the with the
Montreal launch we now have Canada but
there are other parts of the world that
still need GCP and so my ask to you is
take a look at that link yeah bit dot ly
/ GCP regions it's a Google form that
you can fill out and it comes right to
Dave and I and you can tell us what you
think yeah tell us where you want us to
go and tell us what we should bring when
we get there oh yeah so where do we want
to open a region where they want to open
a region and what services do we do they
want us to put their absolutely knowing
that's banner and BigTable and the other
one it's gonna all be their big query
big query thank you though already
coming but there are a lot of services
in GCP it's a big stack so I could
always use help from folks prioritizing
what should come next okay that is the
last slide we are now ready to answer
questions perfect stay tuned for the
live Q&A it'll begin in about one minute
you
okay we got our questions and you want
me to dive in first how about I read
them and you answer even better
questions from the audience thank you so
much for leaving questions if you don't
see your question answered by us now you
can go ahead and tweet either one of us
on Twitter or you can go and fill out
that bitly slash GCP regions there's
probably a thing at the bottom that says
leave a note that note will come
directly to us so easy to get all of us
okay first question how many total
regions are you planning on building 32
if 40 42 is the answer right sky to the
galaxy yes no that actually I get this
question a lot even internally at Google
like when do we stop the answer is when
customers really stop asking us for new
regions we look and this is combined
with that second question as well as how
do you choose where to build regions so
it's all based on customer demand we
look at the attributes that customers
want from us whether it's latency
whether it's where they can store their
data how many locations they need to
meet their availability guidelines which
varies by industry right we have a lot
of customers that we've already on
boarded onto cloud but we know it's not
an easy journey particularly if you're
in an industry that has a lot of
regulatory requirements that you need to
work around that's why we're bringing
these regions to you to meet you
where you're at geographically and also
in the state that you're in
and so to answer the first question we
don't have a number
we'll build until customers tell us to
stop nice that's good yeah if we're
putting numbers on I think we'll build
less than a hundred yeah that makes
sense we have a hundred points of
presence around the world so in the
expanse of time we could imagine having
a region on top of each one of those but
I imagine over time those get re shifted
around as customers demand them in
different locations so yeah yep and it's
the definition of locations will also
continue to grow as well I think we'll
get closer and closer to customers as
we've discovered how important latency
is and a lot of the applications that we
build I think the market will start to
understand have a better appreciation
for how important that is and be able to
pick what parts of their applications
need to be super close to customers and
which ones don't
definition of region might change too
absolutely might get closer and closer
to customers yeah okay
question number two how do you choose
where to build regions that one I
covered right we pick it all based on
customer demand so it's constantly out
talking to the market figuring out what
they need and then prioritizing really
based on the needs of our customers we
have a huge customer base all over the
world a lot of our customers are global
enterprises so we find their needs are
expansive all over the world so they're
looking for us to do that work to all
the data center work in order to give
them that single GCP API mm-hmm
everywhere so I guess the answer to that
question is bit Lee / GCP regions yep
fill out the form Dave and I find out
yeah question number three what changed
in your building strategy to enable you
to launch regions faster yeah so may she
own yeah that's a great question
automation is is the Morrigan's are like
one element that I might not have
expected is included within automation
mm-hmm yeah it's there are actually two
answers to this question the first part
is automation and it's so getting
repeatability so we want to stamp these
things out and get the same footprint
everywhere so that we're not really in
our architecture so we use the same
architecture everywhere that's key
homogeneity yep
the second piece is we actually had to
change the way we did data center
infrastructure because you know we have
a huge huge 1 billion customer
applications inside of Google right
search ads Gmail these are huge services
inside of Google that are all cloud
customers they're all built on Google's
data center infrastructure right not
every customer that we have in public
cloud is that size and so we had to
really look at how do we tailor Google
down to the needs of our customers and
really shrink it so we could quickly
bring the technologies that they were
interested to market and then build out
gradually and that's one of the key
differences as well if we had to bring
all of Google right that every part if
you need to run search to a reservist
yes it would take much longer to do this
so we really paired that down into
something that was specific to cloud it
doesn't forget any of the pieces that
GCP needs but it was tailored uniquely
for cloud it's the kind of investment in
something specific to a particular PA in
Google that I haven't seen before so and
that's maybe why every region to begin
with doesn't have every single service
absolutely we're catering to the
customers that have demanded which
services which is why it's so important
the customers go-to bit at least I do
city regions and tell us what they want
please number four is there an
equivalent to GC paying for competitors
data centers yeah there's one for Azure
but I don't know that there's one for
Amazon I also haven't seen one for any
of the other public clouds if you find
me on Twitter and ask me this question I
will try to find out your answer I think
it's an interesting question I would
love to see one that showed all of the
public clouds I mean here's why that
would be interesting that would be
interesting because you'd be able to see
at your spot in my home state of
Minnesota which is the closest cloud
region to me physically that might be
interesting it wouldn't be interesting
because it wouldn't take account of
going over private networks for example
if you were using our private network
GCP is the largest private network in
the world you have access to it every
time you use TCP you don't have access
to it if you're not using GCP and so not
always does proximity in terms of pings
over public transport equate to alacrity
of actual experience with cloud so what
I mean it's more complicated you might
want to actually like boot up a workload
in each of those clouds and then do it
and then go over the private be like
more complicated yeah tweet me I'll find
you answer number five what are the
metrics or features that determine a
region and who are the people that are
involved in this process yeah well we
have a I guess if you think about what
it is we use to decide whether we go
what triggers I think is the question
here what triggers a new region for us
it's about product market fit so I have
a product that I can take to market
today I have a new region in that set of
products that I'm launching with today
and we make a minimum infrastructure
investment so we have to see that
there's demand and the
market for that kind of investment and
so we bring together our sales team
that's out working with customers to
assess their demand in that location
we're talking four new customers we're
talking a lot to our existing customers
these global multinationals who are
looking to spread their infrastructure
or their applications around the world
and then we have all the internal
stakeholders we actually have a number
of internal services at at Google who
want to get to these new regions as
quickly as they can as well so we
balance the needs of all of those
stakeholders it's not just our public
customers but there are a lot of
internal I get emails every day from
Google engineers and different services
who want access to these new new regions
because they want to use computer
storage or big table or spanner that is
available publicly to everybody else but
they want to use it for some of our
internal problems correctly correct wow
that's great
yeah geonji yes geonji nice those are
the five questions thank you all so much
for the time this was the third of three
webinars we do these webinars every
single Tuesday and they keep getting
bigger and better and more interesting
so tune in next Tuesday and learn more
about what's hot and new on GCP thanks a
lot
awesome thanks Neil see ya at the next
region lost you the next recent lunch
see you Dave
you